c'était mon premier amour
le premier c'est un brouillon c'est rien
c'est la merde s'en sortira jamais avec
sa souris cieux on a décidé de te faire
suivre un programme pour ne pas te faire
oublier et l'ina vous êtes super relou
en fait mon poussin j'ai pu 50 premières
étapes et lina études puis quoi put
kaunas [ __ ] [ __ ] morue non il
faut que les gens tirent maintenant faut
que la fasse tomber de son piédestal où
un grand coup non mais bon c'est une
image mission ira frontalement grâce
braquet
je dis ça
non mais ça va pas ça fait partie du
programme
à chaque fois qu'un lieu tu auras
pèlerinage je t'en remettre une pourquoi
je joue au tennis avec vous moi je vais
très bon c'est bon
louise je te signale que si où tu as
fait tes aussi pour pouvoir jouer en
double c'est pas un mec tu seras content
d'eux qu'on fasse la même chose pour toi
surtout si t'a largué comme une vieille
merde on n'était pas non plus un canon
il vous l'aimiez pas en fait c'est ça
sûr qu'on fait pas une colline lui ouvre
les yeux ça pique un peu c'est normal
moi lâche moi qui l'a choisi la voie la
[Musique]
bike polo trou trop mignon